Il y a le nouveau Star Wars qui est sorti !
Le nouveau Star Wars quoi !
Je sais pas, je sais pas si vous vous rendez compte,
je sais pas si vous l'avez vu.
Moi non.
Donc voilà, je vais pas faire une critique du film,
ça n'a aucun sens
puisque je ne l'ai pas vu.
Non, par contre, je re-matais les anciens,
et je me suis mis à la place d'un Sith
et je me suis dit que les Jedi étaient quand même assez méchants.
Du coup je me suis demandé,
est-ce qu'il y a vraiment un côté obscur de la force ?
Déjà, si vous connaissez pas Star Wars,
eh bien j'espère sincèrement que tout va bien dans votre monde parallèle.
Pour les autres, vous inquiétez pas, il n'y aura du coup aucun spoil, sur l'épisode 7
puisque je ne l'ai toujours pas vu depuis le générique.
J'ai toujours kiffé Star Wars et notamment pour un truc que je trouve incroyable :
C'est la Force.
Tu vois, cette énergie qui est dans tout l'univers,
Comme dirais Ben Kenobi, "Elle nous entoure et nous pénètre".
J'ai beaucoup de respect pour Ben Kenobi, vraiment.
"Elle nous entoure et nous pénètre. C'est ce qui lie la galaxie en un tout uni.
Alors moi ça me fait vachement penser à la définition de Dieu
de Spinoza, dont je vous avais déjà parlé
dans un Coup de Phil', je vous mets le lien en description.
Mais ce que je retiens ici c'est l'idée du "tout uni".
Or dans la Force, il y a deux cotés distincts,
il y a le coté obscur et le coté clair
MAIS OUI C'EST CLAIR
Ils sont distincts à tous les niveaux
Il y'a par exemple des musiques différentes
*tin tin tin tin tin tin*
*ta ta tiiiin tiiiiiiiiin nin nin niiiiin*
Ils ont aussi des couleurs très marquées hein,
tous les jedis sont en blanc, tous les siths sont en noir.
Genre au point où ils peuvent même pas faire leur lessive ensemble.
Ils ont des vaisseaux différents, des méthodes differentes,
des pouvoirs différents. Bref tout un tas de trucs différents.
Mais en fait vu que la Force c'est un tout uni
et que ses deux aspects sont en fait la négation l'un de l'autre,
c'est à dire que ce qui n'est pas clair est obscur
et ce qui n'est pas obscur est clair
et bah en fait on a un petit peu un équilibre.
Et si ces deux cotés forment un équilibre,
alors ils ont chacun besoin de l'autre pour exister.
Alors en plus de ça, parfois ça s’équilibre tout seul.
Par exemple Anakin, il est passé du coté obscur
en devenant Dark Vador.
Et d'ailleurs on peut noter que c'est l'amour qui l'a fait basculer
L'amour qu'il ressentait pour Padmé.
Alors oui c'est aussi par peur mais c'est une peur qui naît
parce que il tient à Padmé.
D'ailleurs on reparlera de la peur plus tard.
Bref on peut effectivement passer du côté clair au côté obscur
Alors est-ce qu'on peut faire l'inverse ?
euuuuuuuuuuuuuuuh
Oui il y'a Han Solo par exemple,
Han Solo, à la base c'est un contrebandier,
il fuit la galaxie, il a des dettes énormes,
il passe son temps à draguer de la meuf,
il est tellement arrogant que le seul être qui le supporte,
c'est une boule de poils.
On va pas me dire qu'il est du coté clair de la force.
Et pourtant il y passe, puisqu'il rejoint une cause,
la cause des rebelles.
Et qu'il n'agit plus pour lui,
mais pour un idéal qui le dépasse.
Un idéal qui représente le côté clair de la force en plus.
Voilà, et notez aussi qu'il le fait ce basculement
par amour également.
Voilà, mais en tout cas ses deux cotés de la force,
ils sont perméables.
Alors qu'est ce qui fait qu'il y en ait un qui soit obscur,
et l'autre clair ?
Bah en fait, j'pense que ça va pas vous surprendre,
ou alors vous me connaissez mal,
mais en gros, la différence, elle est minime.
Déjà si on prend le côté obscur,
il est obscur parce qu'il est représenté par l'Empire,
c'est des gens qui sont au dessus des lois,
c'est des gens qui tuent pour leurs idées
c'est des gens qui sont animés par la haine,
et qui font des masques beauté non homologués
par EnjoyPhoenix.
Et si on parlait un peu du coté clair de la force ?
Et bien ils sont aussi au dessus des lois en fait.
Le concept des Jedis, quand ils voient que
Palpatine est en train de prendre le pouvoir,
ils décident de se battre.
Alors je suis désolé, mais Palpatine, "Il est dans son droit"
Alors certes, il a menti dans ses intentions,
mais il est dans le système tu vois, genre
on vote pour lui, il a une légitimité.
Or les Jedis, ils sont prêts à affronter ça,
et ce que fait Mace Windu quand il arrive contre Palpatine
pour l'arrêter et se battre contre lui,
bah c'est un coup d'Etat.
Et puis même en règle générale, les Jedis
c'est des chevaliers.
Ils tuent pour leurs idées.
Alors vous me direz peut-être, ils tuent pas par la haine
Ah ouais ? Vraiment ?
Et puis même dans leur manière d'exécuter l'action,
que ce soit les Jedis ou les Siths,
ils se battent avec la même arme,
le Sabre laser, tu vois.
Ils ne se cachent pas derrière des petits Blaster à distance.
Non.
Non là c'est les yeux dans les yeux,
Avec l'art noble de la maîtrise du sabre,
'Fin c'est quand même une arme de vérité.
Et c'est des sabres qui peu importe leur couleur,
illuminent, éclairent
et sont source de lumière quoi.
A un point où tu prend le général Grievous,
tu le retournes, ça fait un lustre.
Alors je suis pas du tout en train de dire que les Jedis sont des Siths
et vice versa, ou que le côté obscur n'existe pas.
Non, ce que je veux juste faire c'est nuancer un petit peu
cette image qu'on a de Star Wars
et de ce côté obscur versus côté clair.
Finalement les deux cotés ils sont très poreux,
et on se rend compte que, la différence
entre ces deux cotés,
bah c'est pas tant de vouloir faire le bien absolu, ou le mal absolu
c'est-à-dire d'être un absolu méchant ou un absolu gentil.
Mais c'est plus un système de valeurs subjectif.
Et ça rejoint ce que j'avais dit dans le "AskCyrusNorth"
numéro 1
-Il est dans la description-
Et au global dans les films on a une vraie transition
entre d'un côté un environnement clair,
donc la république, jusqu'à un environnement obscur
l'empire.
Et ça ce fait en parallèle avec la transition d'Anakin
qui passe du côté clair au côté obscur de la force
Et les deux ont le même moteur,
la peur.
"La peur mène à la colère, la colère mène à la haine,
la haine mène à la..
-Mer noire -Oui!"
Alors Anakin on en a parlé tout à l'heure,
mais pour la République,
Bah Palpatine, il s'est montré comme le plus apte à gérer les problèmes de
la République.
C'est des problèmes qui faisaient peur aux citoyens,
et du coup sans comprendre, ils ont élu quelqu'un,
au sein de la République,
qui les a privés de leurs droits.
Il a fait de la République un Empire.
L'empire n'a pas renversé la République,
l'Empire c'est la République.
En fait Star Wars ça nous montre que
Un politicien peut profiter du sentiment de peur
pour affaiblir la République.
Putain, le Pen c'est Palpatine en fait.
Sauf que nous on a pas de Jedi quoi, enfin on a le jeudi
mais ça sert à rien dans ce cas là..
Après le jeudi en soi c'est cool, moi j'aime bien
Et puis on aurait pu se poser d'autres questions, sur Luke par exemple
regarde, le mec il a pas d'amis,
il cherche un groupe dans lequel il peut donner un sens à sa vie,
il se fait former à l'art de la guerre par des fanatiques,
il est prêt à détruire des trucs immenses, et à y laisser sa vie,
Ce ne serait pas un terroriste radicalisé par hasard ?
C'est une idée que j'ai trouvé amusante qui est issue d'un article de
Slate, et que je mets dans la description.
Faut pas que je rate ma séance.
Bref, voilà petite reflexion sur Star Wars.
J'espère que ça vous a plu, n'hesitez pas à developper
et à débattre de ce dont vous voulez dans les commentaires,
C'est fait pour ça. Ça c'était juste une approche, une optique
il y en a plein d'autres.
Donc voilà, j'espère que ça vous a plu et surtout abonnez vous si c'est pas le cas
pour ne pas rater les prochaines vidéos!
On aurait pu parler de plein d'autres choses,
de toute façon je pense refaire un pop-up sur Star Wars
Vous trouverez ici le pop up numéro 1 sur retour vers le turfu
et ici le dernier épisode du Coup de Phil' sur Hegel
Nous on se revoit dans deux semaines, je vous souhaite un joyeux Noël
et de belles fêtes de fin d'année.
Je vous envoie, du love et de la peace,
Yallaah, yallah, yallah